Salut ! Comme le nom de la chaine l'indique, je m'appelle Fabien Olicard
Et je suis mentaliste
Alors techniquement ça veut dire quoi ?
Ça veut dire que des fois je suis sur scène en spectacle,
que d'autres fois j'écris des livres sur ce sujet,
mais que la majeur partie de mon temps je la passe sur Youtube à vous faire des vidéos
soit pour essayer de vous bluffer en bluffant d'autres personnes
ou alors en vous expliquant des choses et en vous donnant des astuces de mentalisme
mais d'une manière générale, l'idée c'est de se marrer
de faire des trucs fun et qui aient toujours un rapport plus ou moins lointain avec le cerveau
Voilà ! C'est la synthèse que j'essayais de faire.
Hé ! Abonnez-vous.